ces quatre étudiants néo brunswickois
sont et bienne après le 6 décembre 1989
après la tragédie de polytechnique
voici molly charles emilie et
charles-alexandre trois décennies plus
tard en dehors du québec
qu'est ce que les jeunes connaissent de
cette tragédie on leur a demandé tous
sur charles alexandre on avait entendu
parler mais vaguement vervialle
entendeur coop odeurs cet événement donc
je veux apprendre aujourd'hui et à côté
puis on leur a fait regarder un
documentaire sur le sujet pour ensuite
en discuter
vrai on n'est pas défini premières
réactions à chaud des images que vous
avez
car si chacun a fait violent on
s'imagine jamais que ça peut être autant
pire autant extrême que si je comprends
pas pourquoi quelqu'un france a juste ça
m'a choqué de sharp a aucune chose à
beaucoup de saint pie x est arrivé pas
si longtemps pensé mais aussi
n'envisageait pas que le lendemain qui
veut directement que c'était fini que et
pour moi c'était pas quelque chose non
plus on a tous des pleins de vie qu on
est malades dialysés
[Musique]
emilie elle qui fait partie des 24 % de
filles seulement inscrits en ingénierie
à l'université de moncton s'est senti
directement interpellé c'est à dire
avoir fait faire une image qui n'est pas
au préfet l'a regardé les quatre
s'entendent pour dire que la violence
faite aux femmes est un sujet dont il
parle plus entre eux et à l'école je
pense que c'est dommage que ça prend ça
pour qu'on commence à lampard aurait
contenu de la conversation au sujet de
la violence conjugale que des lentilles
féminin comment vous avec la guerre
mondiale on continuera les pions mara
pop ou pas sûr qu'il n'ya pas de moi
comme ça ne va pas
même si on voit qu'on n'a pas peur plus
que ça avec l'événement qui arrivait au
québec si peu qu'ils ignoraient même
l'existence du terme féministes qui elle
entendue par les semences ministre
d'avoir aujourd'hui
donc personne d'entendre l'histoire
comme de tous s'entendent pour dire
aussi que la quête de l'égalité entre
les sexes watts inclure tous et chacun
il faut dire que c'est pas un attaquant
20 les hommes sait pas quand les hommes
que les féministes travail ou que quand
ce qu'on ait présenté des documentaires
c'est vraiment il faut les hommes se
battre avec les femmes pour l égalité
pour que ces choses ne se reproduisent
plus oui parce que moi dans mon sens
quand ce que ces choses arrivent c'est
toute la société qui est 8e c'est toute
la société qui paie pour ça lever la
main ce qui se dit féministe
comme quoi on parle et fait partie de la
solution ici elisa série radio canada
moncton
[Musique]